here we go
so I got that up just half of everything
else that I had intended to have up and
running up and running yet because that
this is how I roll
apparently even when I try and have
things more pulled together than this
this is still ends up being ultimately
the way in which I roll how's everybody
doing tonight doing pretty well I hope
the the idea behind the topic is that I
actually had to be reminded that most
most TV shows are starting up their new
seasons which I always forget because I
you know I get almost everything through
streaming and most things I'm more than
happy to wait a few months until the
things over to just binge it all later
so like I'm not caught up on anything
and there's very few things that I'm
gonna catch as they air that said I am
gonna try and keep pace with the good
place which is I mean that's that's the
big one that's that's going on this
season of television that I have much
interest in and of course it's the last
season which I'm sad about but also is
probably smart it's not really a concept
for a show that was gonna sustain itself
into oblivion
so you know I think it's it's good to
figure out where to where to end and
just go ahead and do that so okay now
I've got the chat up and running hey hey
there Cara how was my day um having some
repeat frustration verses are not verses
but like similar to stuff that I've
already had to deal with in the past cuz
the company that I work for
changed insurance plans again I'm gonna
tip that back up slightly because I am
it picky and they did this last year too
so last year it disrupted my
prescription refills and it's doing it
again so I'm a little frustrated myself
overall but you know standard day for
the most part Supernatural is finally
ending yeah I heard that is one of those
shows I never got into so is anyone here
outside the US oh yeah
world of movies you'll find quite a few
folks outside the US kicking around see
you've got the iconic American green
lamp I see that was my grandfather's
lamp before the record just rewatched
Dark Crystal in your review ready for
age of resistance age of resistance is
great I really do like that I'm I'm
keeping an eye out for for when the
another season gets announced god I hope
they get to do more like I'm not taking
it as a given cuz I have no doubt that
thing was expensive I feel you're paying
our dental got jerked around last year
yeah yeah Kara win it huh this stuff is
it never goes as smoothly as it as it
should
second day of autumn which living in the
south means nothing well around here it
means the leaves are turning which is
really nice for the you know a few weeks
until we hit peak and then about a week
after peak foliage you know I'll just
drop to the ground and we'll have brown
leaves all over the ground and twigs in
the air until the snow hits so you know
you can you decide for yourself that
that's better
I've been learning the Doctor Who TT RPG
on tabletop role-playing game it's been
fun creating my one shot which is easy
to learn very cool
oh somebody from England folks sharing
their
their countries of origin if they're
outside the US 100 degree weather yeah
you can keep that yeah I have no
particular interest in that us no what's
that like snow is lovely until about
midway through January and by the time
February starts I'm done with it I'm
over it it's really nice during the
holidays like it's nice and festive it's
I mean a white Christmas it's kind of
nice I do dig it and but you know I
don't I don't ski I don't snowmobile I
don't do winter snow activities I'm you
know that are like major commitments so
yeah you know come February I'm done
with the snow but snow get around here
can hang around until April usually with
one errant snowfall in May
thank you very much Amanda weekly chip
incent with gratitude for your work
thank you very so much very so much what
yeah mm-hmm I can speak what's your
favorite spin-off from any show my money
is on angel or maybe legends of tomorrow
um those would definitely be hot
contenders I'm trying to think of it as
anything else that I would consider to
be a really top-notch spin-off Frasier
was really good that's just kind of off
the top of my head at this point I mean
it is angel battling with legends of
tomorrow I mean I definitely consider
legends of tomorrow to be the best CW DC
show period so that's easily better than
the rest of it I do tend to think angel
is better than Buffy personally which of
those two I would rank highest I'm
probably gonna have to wait until
legends of tomorrow ends before I can
answer that which is something that I
hope does not happen for a very long
time because I'm like good place which
should have an endpoint
legend of tomorrow something that could
continue into infinity and I would like
it to it won't but I'd like it to what
you got there I have water
that's the official story and I am
sticking to it do you have any advice on
recording your voice um yeah don't skimp
on the equipment I mean that that's
seriously the best advice that I can
give you editing software especially
audio editing software there's plenty of
free stuff so you don't even have to
worry about that but you need a decent
mic and you know you need a whatever you
have the mic plugged into that you can
you know you can work around that even
if you like just plug it into your phone
depending if you have a phone with it
with that kind of jack but what have you
but like be prepared to spend over a
hundred bucks on a mic because short of
that it's gonna be able to tell and hear
that it's not the best quality and I
don't have the best mic in the world
either let me be absolutely clear on
that but I I when I first started
shooting videos I went for a cut-rate
camera and the best mic that I knew I
could handle cuz things much better than
what I got out which I still use would
have sort of entered into a territory
that it's somebody more knowledgeable
could have done something with it but me
it would have been just throwing money
away
have you ever watch crazy ex-girlfriend
yes my um my partner and I we actually
watched that together which means we're
working through it very slowly cuz we're
not always in the mood for it but we are
into season two and enjoying it quite a
bit
favorite Harry Potter costume huh you
mean like I within the film series are
like done as a cosplay because I always
get a kick out of seeing lunar or Hagrid
done as a cosplay within the within the
confines of the film's themselves oh I
don't know I think the the redesigns on
the Death Eaters for Harry Potter and
the order of Phoenix
we're quite neat I like those quite a
bit to clarify I meant getting used to
your own voice on-camera practice I mean
like I I don't really know what advice
to give for someone who's like how do
you get comfortable in front of a camera
cuz I always was like I I'm I'm a bit of
a performer by nature I I did theatre
I'm sorry yes there we go I did theater
in high school and into college I'm used
to just speaking and it's something that
comes very naturally to me so when
people trying you know ask me how do you
get comfortable like I'm I have
narcissistic and exhibitionistic
tendencies so like I I like an audience
and I'm used to presuming that I have
one might be a little choir this streem
feeling tired oh that's okay King you
know whatever whatever keeps you going
don't worry about it can you tell me
some positives about the twin dilemma I
want to watch it but I can't bring
myself to do it so need some motivation
as I've heard about its negative
reputation I mean here's the thing if
you've heard all the bad stuff said
about it it's not as bad as all that
stuff would lead you to believe it's not
good but you know for all the stuff
people say about it it's not the worst
thing in the world but I don't have any
particular positives to say about it
that's Slytherin schoolgirl outfit is
awfully cute Oh Carolyn they're you
devious backup here remember last week
when I said me and my friend were going
to watch children of Earth well we did
last week I think she's going to pick
what we watch next time I think if she
sat through children of Earth and came
out the other side of it she has earned
that
right don't even argue with her did you
ever plan to visit Brazil someday a big
shout out from your Brazilian fan here
oh thank you so much like I don't have
any plans like I I don't have any big
exotic travel plans in my life right now
just cuz like between time and money
it's just not in the cards for me like
I'm barely gonna be able to make it out
just a la for Gallifrey one in February
so Brazil the very ideas incredibly
intimidating very cool but very
intimidating back up sorry
losing track of a thing I I'm trying to
keep up with the questions as best I can
but boy things really really zip by
these days what's your favorite show
that nobody has probably seen I mean my
favorite show that not many people
remember is the MTV animated version of
the max which might honestly be my
favorite complete piece of television
ever I'd love that thing to absolute
death and I think it's amazing but it's
not something that has ever gotten much
of a much of a second life you know it
aired it reared a little in the mid 90s
but it never got another season it
didn't get any kind of follow-up the way
something like Aeon Flux did so it
hasn't had much of an afterlife after
that original airing so unless you were
there which I was most people haven't
seen it and don't know it fan of the
show black books I have not seen that
one so I could not tell you my favorite
show is Dark Shadows I that's that's why
I have a fair number of friends who
either got into or have gotten into Dark
Shadows that's one I've never never had
the chance to give a shot to
I don't know if called the Midwife as a
show you'd be into who but as recent
seasons take place in the 60s I think my
mother watches Call the Midwife I think
so are you into the fan productions uh
about Doctor Who like fan series audio
dramas comic samples and so on
um like I have a base level awareness of
them I've seen a couple like I'm I
mostly fan film stuff and I've been very
impressed with the production value that
some of these things are able to pull
off
I don't like massively follow them and
it's not something I generally seek out
not because I don't find it interesting
just because you know only so many hours
in the day and that's just not where I
tend to hella came my time and also um
you know I have the dream in my head of
a fan film and like it would be crazy
short like in my mind I have something
very specific in mind it would be about
a minute and it would be super self
indulgent on my part but like I I think
about that like ah that'd be cool and
then I'm like uh I really would need to
get somebody who could do effects worth
a door and I would need to be able to
either build or fake a TARDIS interior
and then my brain just kind of falls out
just even thinking about that
um so fan films are one of those things
that like I enjoy but I watch and then
it gets me wanting to do that which is
kind of dangerous for me cuz I've got
enough I've got enough things in the
fire whatever the phrase is um as it
stands so I don't need more more pet
projects you said you watched flash for
the first two seasons what did you think
of their take on reverse flash um I
thought it was fine um I mean I liked I
liked him in season one best being
played by I can't remember the actor's
name but then you know later on when he
can't like when he came back for season
two of legends of tomorrow it was a
different actor and I and I know why I
understand the logistics of why
did that and everything but I like the
the guy who played it in season one
better then than the other guy the other
guy was fine and I can't remember
anybody's name so if you ever watch
these shows you don't know what the heck
I'm talking about but you know there you
go what music do you enjoy any guilty
pleasures okay
those are both drink questions and you
knew that Oh
devious I'll take it I thought you might
thank you very much Lucas much
appreciated
alright let me see if I can do something
vaguely close to catching up what do you
think about Jonah Hill in the Batman has
a villain new rumor I saw the rumor
until I know what parties playing I have
no opinion and until it's come I mean
until I know what parties supposedly
playing I have absolutely no opinion and
even when after I hear that I only have
a tiny opinion until it's confirmed so
do you think you might do a list ranking
of the regeneration stories oh yeah
that'll happen eventually it's on the
dock and it's been actually it's been an
option when I had one cuz I put the list
topics up for a vote on the patreon page
and that one has been offered up a few
times but that but the patreon
supporters have opted for all their
lists so it'll get done eventually like
I have tons of lists
you know ID tons of my list ideas either
ones to revisit that I've done before in
need updating or whole new ones but you
know I try not to do more than one list
a month and that gets ultimately decided
by by the folks over on patreon so if
you want a voice in that that's that's
where you can go I am shameless and yet
still ashamed that doesn't work oh yeah
Tracy thank you
is there a show that does not have a
spin-off that you would like to see and
what would the spin-off be about first
thing I have to top my head as much as I
was really done
with the Netflix Marvel shows to the
point that I actually still haven't
watched Justin's season 3 past the first
episode I genuinely would have liked to
see them take a crack at daughters of
the Dragon and pair up misty 9 Colleen
Wayne I would have been down for that if
they moved away from the grim dark vibe
and went for the fun sort of
exploitation era of films vibe that
their comics have when those two have
been paired up so that's the that's the
big one off the top my head sorry try
guys is so I can't remember more drink
questions you want it you all want to
help you you're dangerous you are do you
plan to watch Torchwood miracle day will
you will you ever watch it
have you seen class greetings from
Poland um I've always kind of figured
that
Torchwood miracle day and class are they
just kind of fall into the eventually
someday I'm sure I will but like I have
never prioritized those above other
stuff that I have to do so like I I
probably will but like I have no idea
when I'll get to that
are there any cliches and TV or movie
shows that you're sick of more than I
could actually probably think of how to
go examples the heroes are you'd split
up before the final battle only to get
back together again
yeah there's stuff like that like Mike
my big recurring one is always
unnecessary romantic relationships and
I'm also someone who feels that about
90% of romantic relationships are
unnecessary in most media they can work
sometimes there's actually been more
stuff in the show's that I like where
I've been seeing at work which is
surprising to me but I don't so I don't
know if I'm just
watching the right shows or if the
writers and show producers are finally
getting smarter and not just doing it
because oh well there's supposed to be a
love story there doesn't have to be if
not all stories need that so that's
always the the main one that I beat the
drama that I'm absolutely sick of but
broadly speaking Oh prophecy if I never
hear the word prophecy again and a
fantasy story it'll be too soon I'm so
sick of that ah never want to hear that
one again
like even subverting it I'm so done with
prophecies did you know the musical A
Chorus Line is being adapted into a
Netflix series a series not like just a
not just a 1-up but like a series out of
course I mean I get I guess you could
given the format of the show but like
I'm not sure that's gonna sustain a
series that's uh that's an odd pick that
is come on thank you very much Matt
greatly appreciated a new fan we would
give more but I have a I have a bun in
the oven on the way best of luck on that
because that that is a throw right at a
roller coaster so Cheers mine turned
eight not too long ago so it's uh it's a
ride got a call from the same Washington
DC number twice in almost two hours
wrong number or having tons something I
mean these days I don't know could be
both
okay does anyone watch tall girl on
Netflix the premise did not three me I
saw the trailer for that and I was like
I wanted to find a reason that it didn't
look awful but I couldn't find it
what's the worst three movies you've
ever seen oh geez
now please here's the thing I'm not
gonna try and name like the worst made
three movies I've ever seen because I
actually actively avoid stuff that I
think is just going to be badly made cuz
I don't go in for the so bad it's good
thing as a rule of thumb so these are
just these are just gonna be movies that
I think are bad and I vehemently hate so
if I'm trying to think of three first
ones on my head first movie that I ever
remember hating not just disliking but
hating was dead man Jim Jarmusch film oh
god do I hate that movie holy crap and
it's not even that absolutely everything
in it is terrible there's like one good
character and and story thread but
somehow that makes it worse that there's
one good thing and this see
self-indulgent garbage I don't actually
hate it it does have so bad it's good
qualities but you know what's really bad
have you ever seen the animated film
Fire and Ice wow it's bad that that
one's a special kind of amazing bad and
I guess to round that out
just to sort of make my point that I how
I usually don't go for so bad it's good
like one of the quintessential so bad is
good movies as a robot monster which I
watched like I did not have fun watching
this and it is absolutely awful is there
such a thing as a flawless Doctor Who
story I mean it depends on how you're
measuring it if you're trying to look at
it like a narrative puzzle probably
there might be a doctor whose story that
either has no plot holes
or no potholes they could not somehow be
explained by the very nature of the
doctor being a time traveler but I mean
if you're asking me if there's a perfect
pristine everyone will love it well no
because there's always gonna be stuff
that comes down to personal preference
for my part I put I put city of death
and Heaven Sent right up there
now I haven't rewatched Heaven Sent in a
while so I I then I'm not saying that to
say that it that like my confidence and
it has been shaken but as I've been
doing my rewatch for Doctor Who I am
getting you know more of a more of a
sense of how my memory of something
either is giving you too much credit or
not enough or maybe haha maybe I should
have hated it more than I did in a few
cases which that's a weird experience
kind of excited about the lin-manuel
Miranda's adaptation of in the heights
oh I forgot about that I did hear about
that at some point so let's say before
series 8 Charles dance was rumored to
play the master he would have been good
but I actually think he's got too much
presence Littlefinger's actor would have
been my choice um well okay so series
eight would have been him facing off
against Capaldi I might have agreed with
you with some doctors I think Capaldi
could have gone toe-to-toe with dance um
that said I do love Missy so I'm not
sorry that that didn't happen if it was
ever in consideration and also as much
as I like Charles dance especially at
that point in time where it like
everybody knows him as Tywin Lannister
it almost feels like too obvious a
choice if that makes sense
Oh tick tick boom oh yeah I did I did
hear about tick tick boom which battle
bhi I will be curious to see if they
have the guts to rework that cuz tick
tick boom as it exists is basically rent
the the beta version and and it's not as
well worked out there's some stuff in it
doesn't really go anywhere there's some
songs that aren't very good but there is
some great individual bits of it you
know the the the way that it opens is
terrific and I really love the song
boho days I like that one a lot so what
Batman villain do you think would be
ideal for Pattinson movie I want the
Riddler so bad to be there ah I mean I
don't know I mean the rumor is or the
rumor has been for a while that there's
gonna be a lot of them I think it's in
the best interest to veer away from
anyone who has been in the stuff
recently so I would I would nudge them
towards somebody that either hasn't been
in the movies at all or hasn't been in
the movies for a long time
Riddler will be a solid pick I'd like to
see penguin there but not as the lead
villain
I actually think penguin works best when
he's just sort of a background feature
you have the penguin instead of the
local mob so I wouldn't actually make
him the main focus though but if they're
gonna play up the detective end which is
the word unconfirmed if they're gonna
play up the detective element a bit more
then the Riddler is kind of the ideal
pick say so all right can I get a quick
Joker impression any Joker oh dear all
like my if as far as doing an actual
impression as opposed to just you know
doing the Joker laughs I the only one I
can really do much of it in person I
mean I can kind of do a Joe the only I
can do much of an impersonation of is
the Mark Hamill let me see if I can pull
a line okay so I'm probably gonna end up
pulling a line from
return of the Joker which I love oh it's
the new boy is a to long
I'm gonna miss the Cape but not too
shabby not too shabby at all I love fire
and ice like I said there's
entertainment to be had that's oh man
it's bad holy cow so bad it's good the
Super Mario Brothers movie I have not
rewatched that thing in a is ah this
dang I wish I could get this thing to
behave in a way that makes sense to me
I seem to not be able to do is it sad
that I only know Charles dance as the
Phantom of the Opera
when does Charles dance Phantom of the
Opera how did how is this news to me uh
what's your favorite time travel paradox
that's explored in media grandfather
paradox bootstrap paradox um I don't
know enough of the enough of the the
paradoxes by name I mean I've I've
always just been partial to just what I
consider to be the circular model of
time which don't even necessarily
consider to be a paradox it's just
stories that basically look at time as
this rather than this so twelve Monkeys
is kind of a good go-to example for that
but I often top my head I don't know
enough of the the names for different
paradoxes and thought experiments to
just sort of rattle them off does anyone
know Charles dance from Ali G in the
house Oh God
poor man no although you want to move
your I saw Charles dance in that I keep
remembering and for some reason it won't
clear from my head space truckers that
is riedle it is not bad enough to be
worth seeking out and it's not good
enough to see on its own merits but who
oh boy that was a thing and I did see it
he played the phantom and a TV movie
that was made in 1990 with Burt
Lancaster hmm all right
his trial of a Time Lord good I don't
know
I still have seen that one last action
hero I've every watched that one in a
while either hold on I'm just oh boy
you guys are so active I love it but it
is hard for me to keep up return to the
Joker's my fave met wilfred L at the Fan
Expo in Boston this - you're very cool
still at the Pattinson Batman movie
subject who would you cast as the
Riddler oh I have no idea I'm a horrible
person to ask for dream casting I just
I'd I'm not good at getting my head into
that space I'm not a good person to
engage in that like one of the few times
I've done it like when I did it with
actors who might be able to play Doctor
Who like that took me a frustratingly
long time like to force myself to engage
in that exercise my brain does not does
not lend itself to that sort of thing
why are you ignoring me I'm not ignoring
you man I'm trying to keep up with
what's going on there's a lot of stuff
whizzing past me if you think I'm
reading every single thing you're you're
nuts I'm doing my best here haven't we
had this back-and-forth before I feel
like I've had this conversation before
maybe it was with someone else but I
don't know man I'm not trying to ignore
anyone grandfather paradox is where you
kill your grandfather and you're never
born bootstrap is a cycle with no clear
beginning doctor who wrote babe Tobin's
v well yeah I mean the bootstrap paradox
I remember cuz Capaldi as is his
monologue on it oh my god I didn't
remember dance was in Last Action Hero
ignore council gates and hunt down space
truckers I mean if you've got a nose for
I think it was late nineties cheese I
mean go ahead hello I just shot somebody
and I didn't do it on purpose
well regardless of the reason I would
call the authorities would you take Tim
Curry as the master in some form well I
mean at this point he's is very much
retired but at a previous point like 90s
yeah I would have taken him over Johnson
certainly have you seen the clever dick
film reviews of Doctor Who it's very
good in-depth analysis of the history of
Doctor Who I have not seen that what
would be your nightmare worst possible
TARDIS team hmm I guess I don't even
have to think that hard I the Mel and
the Sixth Doctor TV era six doctors six
doctors only good in audio so that's
that's I and that's already a thing that
exists
I watched 155 Doctor Who episodes
congratulations
hope you felt it was worth it I usually
do weird selections but have you seen my
three favorite shows American Horror
Story yes but not all of it I've only
seen through season
I think I'm I've missed the last few
seasons of that series of unfortunate
events I did three episodes it was good
but it wasn't hooking me so I moved on
the League of Gentlemen never watched
that one oh my god the the chat is
really not cooperating with me what
about the whole situation of Matt Smith
casting and the rise of Skywalker do you
think he's actually gonna be in that
movie no I don't I'm pretty sure he was
cast in a part that was cut it's
happened before he was originally in in
Bruges in a flashback sequence it was
before he was Doctor Who but still dudes
been cut from movies before have you
seen Dirk gently's holistic detective
agency first of all which version second
of all doesn't matter I haven't seen any
of them I've only ever read the books
do you think 11th doctor and Donna Noble
book would be a good combo
maybe I mean I would happily put Donna
with literally anybody but I'd be more
interested in putting her with 12 than
11 personally and also like I Amy and
Rory are so good with 11 Clara and 10
would be my least favorite oh yeah I
could see that not working Angie and
Hardy and the thirteenth doctor Oh God
Angie and Artie Oh Oh Kirsten names Oh
God
forgot that they technically made my
criteria when I did the the overall list
nine Ryan and Mickey is my dream TARDIS
team oh that would be interesting god
sakes stop skipping past your darn thing
worst hardest team would be TV 6and Mel
someone's got a lot of trial of a Time
Lord yeah well like I said I haven't
seen it yet so let's see would you ever
consider doing a best and worst Xena
episodes season videos to discuss now if
you like I've only ever seen like a
couple of episodes of Xena so I would
have to carve out time to watch the
entire series and I don't have the time
someday someday maybe
I haven't gotten into American Horror
Story my daughter quite likes it it's an
acquired taste
it's a weird sort of vibe and it also
varies from season to season first
doctor Rory Williams is a good team up
or a bad one because I don't know I mean
I like Rory but like doing Rory without
a me first of all strikes me as a bit of
an odd thing to do I seem random but
what is your favorite story from each
doctor um keeping in mind that I still
have a lot of holes in my classic who
knowledge so there's a lot of stuff I
still haven't seen yet see if I can get
this in order Dalek invasion of Earth
tombs of the Cyberman
time warrior city of death caves caves
of Androzani vengeance on bars by
default remembrance of the Daleks night
of the doctor for eighth we'll skip the
movie
yes day of the doctor for the war doctor
empty child doctor dances for nine I
really go back and forth between the
library two-parter and midnight for 10
tonight I'm gonna save the library
two-parter eleven I don't know I'm in
the middle of reassessing that cuz I'm
in the middle of the rewatch on that
historically it's been eleventh hour I'm
not sure if that'll stay the same twelve
that's Heaven Sent thirteen it's it
takes you away and that's as of tonight
so don't like when I answer this
question again next time it gets asked
don't be like before you say yeah this
is all fluid my opinions change my
feelings change my assessments change
Charlie Pollard needs to be on the show
she such a good character yeah she's
pretty good regardless of the quality of
store
do you feel that series 11 succeeded at
being a good starting point for new fans
yeah about as well as as series 1 or
series 5 or series 10 were yeah sure you
can give us a sneak peek of vampires of
Venice um I could but I'm not gonna take
the time to go all the way over there
and get my vampire teeth out so you'll
have to forgive me for that am I the
only who V on our earth who wasn't a fan
of the eleventh hour no you probably
aren't the only one I do think you are
in a minority though do you think you
want to be a vey pronoun um I don't I
mean I don't have strong opinions on my
pronouns so I don't want to be anything
I just don't I the only thing I want is
for people not to wield pronouns as a
weapon at me not to mock me with them or
not to deliberately use pronouns in
contradiction to how I'm presenting so
you know in order to be jerks which some
people will do so failing back yeah I
did I'm not gonna rule it out ever
favoring they pronouns I don't
I never request them I'm perfectly
comfortable people using them to
describe me and it certainly it works
cuz it means you don't have to flip back
and forth between E and G depending on
how I'm presenting at any given time so
it certainly works and I'm no problem
using with other people using they
pronouns to describe me or refer to me
but I'll never request them just because
it doesn't I know it's awkward for a lot
of people to use a lot of the time and
nothing about being referred to as they
does anything for me any more than he or
she would so knowing that it's it's a
stumble point for some people ya know
it's not something I'm likely to have a
request hi from Australia hey there Ben
Benjamin sorry I don't know I shouldn't
shorten people's names unless
there they've told me that's that's what
they like that's one of my own pet peeve
so I should know better would you like
to see Eric Roberts be back as a master
in the show I don't know I need to
listen to the to the Big Finish that
that he came back on see how he did with
that because as it stands based on his
performance in the TV movie no sorry
just backing up so I'm most trying to
keep an eye out for for Joel my eye my
thumbnail guy he said he might pop in
have you ever discussed your gender with
your daughter
not really but because I haven't really
had to like did I've never sat down to
have a conversation about my gender with
my daughter because she just knows that
I look different at different times and
I have this you know that I wear nail
polish and I sometimes wear dangly
earrings and I dye my hair and you know
she'll pick out a nail polish colors for
me sometimes she seen me in full a full
family look she's unfazed by because for
her that's her normal so no I yet I
haven't like sat down and had a
conversation with her about it if she
ever has questions I hope she'll be
comfortable enough to ask me I'll be
happy to talk to her about it but as it
stands she's very unfazed by this in
terms of gender etc etc how has worked
in the past few weeks well I'm sure
there are people at my job who are not
thrilled because like I've stopped
taking off nail polish to go to work and
I've started wearing not this ring but a
rainbow ring that I picked up at Vermont
pride to work know I've had like one
person comment on the name
and nobody's commented on the ring and
you know it's one of those things to
wear no comments are basically like you
people are not comfortable are you I am
out of craps to give my name is Michael
so I always go by Mike okay cool
Joel was here toward the beginning he
may have stepped out ah that's a bummer
I met I might have missed him yes thank
you for the reminder Carol and I do need
to check the discordant sorry folks hang
on I got a see what is going on here all
right so as a reminder the discord is a
patreon exclusive perk and I do have a
sort of a livestream prep where people
can ask questions that I will absolutely
get to as opposed to the chat here where
if it's not a super chat it's a bit of a
dice roll whether I see it and answer it
or not anyways let's so let's see I'm so
hyped for His Dark Materials on the BBC
and HBO adaptation of Bill Pullman's
book series also happy to see Chicago
med and Law & Order SVU back I keep
forgetting sVU's too long because that I
remember the big deal when they canceled
the main series Chicago mad I've never
seen I like I might check out his dark
materials I never read the books they
they seemed somewhat interesting to me
but not like they never made me going
who need that so I might see it you know
an episode or two see what I think about
it I actually have a show that I like
that I'm fine with a ending find that I
ended this year orange is the new black
I felt it ended more or less at the
right time it could just as well have
ended earlier but it didn't run for so
long that I felt it overstate its
welcome well we're actually gonna
disagree on that because I I watched the
first two seasons first season I didn't
enjoy second season I did but then
speaking with my partner Liz who has
kept up with the show she and other
people said as well second season is the
best season I'm like cool I don't need
to watch more then so that's that's the
show that I kind of I got my my own
taste of but I'm glad you got enjoyment
out of the out of the seasons you got
that's
that's what's important the good places
final season is days away so much joy
and sadness at the same time it's crazy
yeah yeah it is that is a great great
ship oh I actually don't watch many
shows regularly anymore yeah you and me
both I did already been to watch the new
season of 13 reasons why yeah that one I
haven't seen any thoughts on Sam s mail
who made mr. robot doing a new
Battlestar Gallactica show on NBC's
streaming service peacock that won't be
a reboot not really because I still
haven't seen Battlestar Galactica so
whether or not so and his claim is that
it's a story that fits within the
mythology and of the existing Battlestar
material and isn't a reboot which I mean
probably good because it's it's so well
liked that's probably a better way to go
but I don't really have an opinion
because I still haven't seen Battlestar
I just remembered that I actually do
have a TV show I was waiting for it
abused tonight and that is this is us
yep don't know that one either I'm
excited as all get-out for the return of
arrowverse and a couple of weeks like
I'm I I am actually still catching up on
previous season of legends of tomorrow
so but I do love the heck out of that
show did you hear about Eccleston saying
he thinks Billy Piper
should have been the first female doctor
I didn't hear that
but funnily enough she keeps she she
would get rumored I remember she got
rumored when Tennant was leaving that
she was gonna be the next Doctor and
then she got rumored again when Smith
was leaving so he's not the first one to
float the idea I don't think she's ever
been in consideration but like the
whenever the bookies take bets her her
name has usually come up your views on
Game of Thrones winning Best Drama at
the Emmys you know what it was a merit
award it was a grandfathered in
like it that's the kind of wind that got
decided a long time ago was gonna happen
as it was the last season as opposed to
being based on how the ex the last
season actually was because no no that
last season did not deserve any awards
technical Awards maybe cinematography
special effects nothing for writing
nothing for best whatever nothing for
acting no so I I don't care enough about
the Emmys to get upset about that but
you know it's wrong see here how we
doing for time I've got about 10 minutes
left
ah why is this chat hate me so much
you've done a video of favorite doctors
in order will you do arguable best
doctors in order example my favorite is
the 11th but I think fourth is the
arguable best um probably not because I
don't I wouldn't trust myself to come up
with a criteria to judge that by for the
entire thing like I think that's easy
enough to do with your top so like if I
think it's easy enough to distinguish
between favorite and who might I should
be the best for like the top spot but I
actually ranking the whole thing in that
fashion no I don't think I'd actually be
able to do that I'm not trying to enjoy
it if I tried
and he shows you're waiting for the end
so you'll start to binge it no I'm
because if something has ended by the
time I yeah before I get started on it I
almost never get around to it so no not
really you have the cards against
humanity' set behind you every video do
you play I do I haven't in a while but
yeah I played see favorite favorite is
easy best is subjective I mean like if
you're gonna try and rank something as
best outside of your own personal
preferences do you have to come up with
defendable criteria which again that's
not my idea of fun
we need trickster back on the show I
still don't think the trickster what I
just slot into the main show very well I
stand by that
you said Game of Thrones season 8 didn't
deserve an Emmy for best acting as well
as writing were there any other were
there any performances you took issue
with not really but the writing was so
bad that the acting got kneecapped you
know when you're given a bad script with
characters making stupid decisions or
going in directions that don't make
sense there's only so much even the best
actors in the world can do and that's
basically what you're looking at with
Game of Thrones season 8 the acting
wasn't bad but the writing was so bad
that good acting couldn't save it
did you hear about Pelosi moving forward
with an impeachment investigation I did
hear and I have no other comment
favorite Star Wars film a new hope
do you like any of the studio ghibli do
I like any of the students Studio Ghibli
films Totoro no-face yes I like Studio
Ghibli where's the 12th doctor
screwdriver at oh it's right here
yeah change the batteries in it but yeah
right up there with the rest favorite
Skeksis Chamberlain oh all the way
mm-hmm
Skeksis is friend to get flea would you
say it's odd that I'm assist male but
feel very comfortable having a feminine
nickname Gina I don't think it's odd
there probably are people who do I think
that's neat
what about trickster teaming up with
some other villains that were defeated
by the doctor or tricks Livie I mean
like we've seen that already sort of I
mean more or less because because with
the with the Pandorica opens they like
every one of them teamed up like the
trickster was just designed to be the
villain in what is very much a younger
kids show and everything about him
reflects that he was good for his use I
just don't think he's gonna fly in the
main show I'm sorry like I get that you
love him and that's awesome I just don't
think he'd work and if he ever if they
ever bring him in and he does work I'll
be very happy to see that
I love seeing things that I don't think
will work somehow making it work that's
amazing and wonderful and I love it but
I don't think so
Chamberlin moons bothered me so much on
the first watch I just I just love him
as a character so much and like I I'm
I'm not gonna count this as a spoiler
cuz I'm gonna quote it out of top out of
context but just Chamberland with that
he's got that line and again I'm not
gonna give a context for this but just
you took my seat oh there any movies you
recommend to take notes on for writing
at the moment I'm most interested in
horror and dark comedy but I'll take any
movie you recommend um huh so if you're
gonna orange and dark comedy from a
writing perspective
I mean dark comedy I'm always gonna
recommend something like for lions
something that's dark because the very
nature of the thing that it's about is
dark as opposed to it's dark because
it's a standard comedy but also some
people die or another really good one is
the World's Greatest Dad which is a
Robin Robin Williams movie that is
criminally under scene that's a really
good thing to sort of study to see how
comedy is is pulled out of the darkness
of the scenario because again that to me
is a proper dark comedy something that
it just like has the vibe of a normal
comedy except some moments are
gratuitously bleak that's not a proper
dark comedy a dark comedy is finding
humor in something that should never be
funny but they find a way to make it
funny wood while still acknowledging
that darkness so for lions World's
Greatest Dad for horror um I'm not
always the best to ask for horror
because I've said in the past
I'm more into horror adjacent like it's
part of why I really like yeonil del
Toro because his movies are rarely
straight-up horror stories but they're
draped in the horror ephemera that I
really like you know mom
sterzin gothic imagery and and severe
lighting and all that sort of stuff but
I don't like core narratives all that
often
I mean scariest movie to me though if
you want to look at something
structurally that is built and designed
from the ground up to unnerve you at
every step at an escalating scale the
1978 invasion of the body snatchers if
you do not feel paranoia by the time
that things over I don't know what to
tell you I just wanted to say that you
and a few other channels inspired me to
start a channel oh that's great J gonna
start posting it December just wanted to
say how Bruin you are thanks well thank
you
any issues with the original trilogy
what the original Star Wars trilogy no
but that's also because I'm nostalgia
blind on that I grew up I literally grew
up watching those so I'm never gonna
I really can't look at those objectively
I'm never gonna be able to do you think
the Slovenian 40 I mean they could
return regardless I wouldn't want them
to return unless they remove the farting
but like I like Boomtown better than the
Slitheen two-parter but a big part of
that has to do with the way a returning
sleuthing character played out I don't
like the species enough to do more with
them and at this point that whole family
is dead so I I don't think there's much
to be gotten out of that am I the only
one who thinks the Goblet of Fire the
book not the film is overrated I heard
people say it's the best I think it's
only because of the ending um I do think
you actually yeah I do think Goblet of
Fire the book and now again this is to
my memory because I haven't actually
reread it in ages so Asterix grain of
salt I actually do agree with that I do
think it is a bit overrated and I think
partially because it's the turning point
for the series it's the point at which
things got serious and I think the
impact of that turn
you know leaves a very potent and very
lasting impression that is not to be
discarded but the book overall like it
was the one that I started reading
and then put down and didn't pick up for
about three months I had a very hard
time getting into it initially I found
the opening all the stuff with the
Quidditch World Cup and all that just
very unengaging and clunky and at that
point like I was done with all of these
these side things just to flesh out the
world of the Wizards I felt like I knew
it pretty well so that didn't interest
me very much and then at the tail end
Voldemort goes on for ever
for out of her book Voldemort one of the
all-time worst mana loggers in the
history of villainy so like there are
some issues that I have with the book
version saving my watch of invasion of
the body snatchers for october and
halloween can't wait for nightmares have
fun with that what is Veterans Star Wars
prequels I mean the only one of the
prequels I really like is Revenge of the
Sith also I have anxiety and I got at 4
a.m. to practice going outside without
feeling anxious or sick and I'll listen
to your videos and it'll seriously help
me thanks for being great oh wow
Thank You Jay I'm wow I'm touched and
honored that that helps you on the
subject of the Goblet of Fire who the
hell how the hell do 6 Death Eaters win
against absence of wizards yeah
especially because later I'd like I you
know what I'm actually kind of okay with
that because no one's expecting to see
the Death Eaters and I think it's just a
panic ensues at the sight of them and
they're counting on that you know when
there's actually an orchestrated defense
against them that they don't they don't
hold off to too strongly
oh channel pop super brief dropping to
stay hot and to say hi I'll be catching
up on this later sending my regards from
Florida I'll tune into one of these
lives live streams again soon well
thanks for stopping in
sorry I missed a nice stream have been
incredibly busy with the show this
evening hey no worries it happens I
think I am gonna be wrapping it up soon
see ah troll dealt with thank you very
much Carolyn nice work
who's your favorite character in the
Eternity of American Horror Story I like
Madison Montgomery I really like it's
been too long since I've seen the second
season but the possessed none know I
love her I think she's great so yeah
quick question before those shows up
with that on your shirt that my friends
that is guy smiley America's favorite
game show host Muppet II goodness
you're saying heroin yeah yeah she is
sister Mary Eunice thank you that was
her she was great what would it take for
you to give preacher or the boys a
chance to spite your feelings about
Garth Ennis um same things that same
thing that it would take for me to give
most things that I don't really have a
lot of interest in seeing a chance
somebody can Amy to watch it I know
that's that's a bit mercenary but that's
the simple truth do you think how
Jeremiah and Gotham was performed would
be a good fit for the master huh I mean
Jeremiah at what point I mean part of
what I don't like about Jeremiah on this
show and I'm probably gonna end on this
note a big part of what I didn't like
about Jeremiah was they spent the
entirety of his time just basically
driving him crazy so that he was just
like Jerome was but why would you do
that we already had your own but because
of that he's actually I was gonna say
inconsistent he's not cuz he's on a
clear trajectory but when you say
perform the master like Jeremiah like at
what point depending what episode you're
watching he doesn't behave the same way
so you'd have to narrow it down by and
large though I'm probably just gonna go
cuz I just don't like that move that
Gotham did it's got the more the watch I
enjoyed it first season is not great
last season unfortunately is not great I
would say that you can skip season five
to be completely honest unless you're
super invested it's not the worst thing
in the world but it's not great you do
need to still see season one to have a
context for series two three and four
which are amazing and the reason to
watch the show
I only watched first of Gotham yeah I
mean that's if that's all you see if you
if you didn't find anything died in the
first season of Gotham even though I
would say it gets better after that if
like there was nothing that was pulling
you in at all it might flat-out just not
be for you Michelle Gomez is awesome and
the chilling adventures of Sabrina I've
heard that have not seen that show so I
am going to wrap up there I hope
everybody has had a good night hope you
had a good weekend hope you have a good
rest of the week we actually stayed on
topic this time pretty much kept it on
TV I'm I am super proud of us way to go
everybody
but I am gonna wrap it up there so I
just want you all to remember that you
are beautiful you are valid you are
loved you are the counsel I'm just
running meetings
have a good night